die feuerwehr rückt auch bei hohen
temperaturen zum löschen aus zum löschen
von durst
den haben wir hier in köln neben den
menschen besonders die bäume bestimmte
exemplare zu wässern sei bei 35 grad
schlicht eine notwendigkeit sagt peter
schmid vom grünflächenamt der stadt köln
straßen wollen wir insbesondere im
bebauten urbanen raum leiden ganz
besonders es ist einfach kein platz
das bisschen platz fest dass die er dass
fünf chancen trocken
deswegen ist es ein segen für die bäume
bei den hohen temperaturen sei auch den
menschen angeraten sich zu bessern
abhilfe verschaffen aber auch
ventilatoren die wie hier in berlin
derzeit in allen möglichen formen größen
und funktionsweisen in unterschiedlichen
preislagen zu haben sind
das ist einfach viel zu heiß bei uns so
und der ein oder andere schon umgekippt
deswegen muss es auf jeden fall jetzt
sagen sie ist nichts zu holen
also ich glaube die machen jetzt diesem
sommer ganze kasse mit ventilatoren
aber trotzdem ich komme aus spanien so
ich bin
daran gewohnt andere setzen lieber auf
ein eis auch das in allen möglichen
variationen eis cappuccino trinken sonst
also wir genießen es ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen die hitze so richtig sommer
feeling zu haben
zum sommer feeling gehört für viele auch
eingang in die natur
wer einen spaziergang durch den wald
plant der sollte aufpassen allzu schnell
ist bei den hohen temperaturen auch in
unseren breiten ein waldbrand entfacht
weiß britta lang leiterin der
oberförsterei fohnsdorf südlich von
berlin
also ein brand entsteht natürlich immer
nur wenn ein funke da ist und alles was
offenes feuer oder auch kleine
gegenstände betrifft nicht in einem
abstand von weniger als 50 metern zum
wald verwenden also das betrifft das
rauchen das betrifft aber auch das
grillen oder auch feuerwerkskörper also
alles was irgendwie damit zu tun hat in
diesem jahr seien im land brandenburg
besonders viele waldbrände zu
verzeichnen
222 allein bisher die kritische zeit sei
aber noch nicht vorbei
üblich seien in einer gesamten
sogenannten waldbrandsaison und 200
brände